about it. I'm just curious. I just want to catch up with you first of all.
and learn about what this is.
like for you. Yeah, yeah. So, um, I mean, it's been
Go pretty well so far. So I've been.
doing it. So AVK design is the
is what I'm doing.
And--
I've been doing it for about eight months.
Right now it's a lot. It's sort of a mishmash
but I'm really trying to this year actually.
of trying to nail it down.
I, my most successful project so far that I've been.
I'm pretty excited about is I won a contract.
You'd be proud of me, I wrote my own proposal.
And I want to contact with the City of Alexandria.
to design their 2040 housing.
which is going to be just like this giant meaty document.
full of visuals and kind of trying to explain.
their plan for the next 20.
I guess 15 years.
and break it down for, you know, every...
person who interacts with Alexandria to be able to understand.
And so I've been super fun so far.
Yeah, you know, I started I wasn't doing a ton of
of that at Blackstone, but those sorts of like--
really big meaty like taking really complex things.
and simplifying them actually.
that way I was doing that kind of stuff with Blackstone.
Yeah, and so that's kind of where I'm.
I think I'm going is trying to position myself, you know, as like the
designer that can help these things.
things, tease them out and kind of make them clear anything.
I think that it sounds like the UX project that you were proposing.
with the scan details obviously.
my fit into that. Yeah, I'm just kind of trying to position but
So keep it open and see, you know, kind of rediscover what
I like to do. Yeah.
That's awesome. I won't make you relive
the it sounds like involuntary termination.
situation that led to this happening, but was that?
Was indicate design in one form another connotation?
just like percolating before then?
- Yeah, I think.
You know, I started software.
I love Blackstone, I went to a company called Sonatype,
which is where I went.
was for the last five years up until.
recently and it started out great and
And I made a lot of progress.
I was creative director there.
I had a team.
And--
And then some new management came in, it wasn't awesome.
And also my, I have a question.
have two kids now.
So--
- Nice to meet you.
Nice. And so that...
just like the complexity of like working for corpora.
and everything. It had been in the back of my mind especially after.
my son was born.
And so when, you know,
I thought I'd move to another company.
and then maybe do my own business thing after.
That's, but then the opportunity like President.
it itself. I was already looking for a job. Wasn't really getting many bites.
And I was like, let's just do it.
Let's just do it.
And it's been--
Great. No.
And so the thing...
that I wanted to kind of really hone in on is like.
What I've been experiencing just in the last few weeks.
weeks is like, I don't have any client.
clients or contracts yet, but I am I have two proposals
submitted so far, which is part of what made me think of
the worm lead and the
The thing that hasn't really happened.
and yet it's been like the just hair.
nor anoia in fear of not having a w2.
Like that's the thing that stops
certainly stopped me before I started doing it.
But I don't know if you can relate to this but like
Staring down the barrel of like doing 30 more years
incorporate and like working for a W.
to employer after just the various things that
that I know I've experienced, just like that's
way scarier than the
uncertainty of going out on your own.
Can you relate to that?
that. Yeah, I think for
For me, it's more of...
Weirdly like it.
the fear of AI.
has been, was, was really feeding into all of us.
a lot of like anxiety that I was having
towards the end of my job.
and still sort of propels me forward, but it's also--
Thank you.
Part of things like, I don't know if...
Designers are going to have W-2 jobs in five percent.
years anyway. So it felt
like a good time to jump and like figure it out on my own.
own and be able to pivot and have like do like the multiple
and come stream things like,
Yeah, and just like the freedom and the freedom.
flexibility.
Yeah, I don't know.
I just like, I really...
Really just like dove in.
Yeah.
was like and you know had a
Um, you know, I still get anxious.
a lot, but for not really.
really any particular reason other than I think I'm still
the hardest thing for me and I wonder if this is
been similar for you is untangling all of the
like 90.
to five corporate love.
I have to be at my desk at night.
I have to sit here until five.
I can't be good.
break. Like it's been so weird.
Like again, like I haven't it's been almost a year.
that I have, I am beholden to
no one, but I still feel so weird.
when we had a two hour delay today and I was like,
"Oh my God, I've so..."
but like I don't I just like I can do whatever I want
whenever I want to. Yeah, that's been like the weirdest.
I didn't think I'd hang out.
I did not realize how deeply embedded all of these.
things have been in my head and in like my
body. Yeah, no, that is a
really good point. Nikki said to me the other day.
Like, bro, you don't have to state your death.
called in and and.
Being away from your desk doesn't mean that you're brave.
brain still isn't totally working on the things.
that it's working on.
And in fact, especially for you.
in the creative space that you're doing.
It preensifies.
You probably benefit distinctly from pulling away.
and then like having fast go in your head.
Yeah, my brain's worse.
all the time, like whether or not I'm actually sitting here and it
is actually far more helpful.
It's one of the things that I was really--
bad about doing when I was during the 9 to 5.
like just like getting with me doesn't like going for a walk.
I still am not brave enough to like go to the gym in the middle of the day, which is
very stupid but you know.
Baby steps. How will do your kids?
My son is 18 months and.
My daughter just started kindergarten. She's five.
- Nice, congratulations.
- Thank you.
- What yours.
So, two girls, Charlie and Billy.
Charlie is going to be six in April. She's
kindergarten and Billy will be for
in July, she just started like the...
Pre-kinder-dunner program here in town.
So awesome.
Are you still local?
You're still here?
No, no, in fact, um...
Not super long after I left Blackstone.
My wife and I got pregnant with Charlie and...
We were like weak.
I can't afford to buy a house in the DMV.
and still be able to
like get to DC in the way that Nikki would have needed to.
And so we just moved on.
Austin instead.
- Wow, that's awesome.
- Yeah.
We're not there anymore in part because
after Billy was born. I like freaked out.
about not having any family nearby.
And so we picked up and moved.
to South Jersey, just outside of Philadelphia.
And like--
That's where my brother's family lives,
and my parents now lives.
So we are all up now in one place and have been so
since 2023.
Are you still out?
It was a Fairfax. Yeah.
That we were living in.
Mm hmm.
I have the benefit of having my in-laws nearby.
So, and I totally, I did not appreciate how.
Because it's like hard either way, but I can't.
I truly can't imagine how much harder it would be.
if we did not have that sort of parental support.
I mean, with my--
families in South Carolina, but by in Los Angeles.
really close and are here all the time in like the best.
- That's a nice spot for us.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, in a way that's not.
obtrusive to you in your house.
- Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, I
I definitely have reaped.
the benefits of living near my family is really great.
Like, I'm--
close with my brother and my parents.
It's South Jersey just sucks like
It's just like, it's not.
There's not a lot of--
cool parts of New Jersey just anyway,
but in South Jersey.
is like not it's not that cool.
So like you live in the Austin.
area where like, I mean, it's an inferno in the
summer, but like it's beautiful most of the time and
like we were able to buy like a new build in Austin.
in 2019. We couldn't do that obviously.
DC and now we come back up here and
It's just like everything is a downgrade.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
That whole lot of fun.
places to build in South Jersey I would have meant.
No.
- No, I do.
- I mean, you know, I'm in a bricky old house, so.
Right, right. I think every like micron
of space has taken up in New Jersey.
Like there's literally--
There's no more space. Yeah, and so yeah
It's that's been a drag especially with days like
today where it's just shitty and terrible outside.
And whereas--
In Texas right now, it's probably the
best time of the year. It's like,
in the 70s all day.
So yeah, I...
You may compromise this when you have kids.
Totally. Yeah.
For you.
Because you have--
so you have a--
daughter was 18 months old? No, my son's 18 months old. My
daughter's
Yeah. So for you.
with the flexibility that you have.
of being self-employed like
I know that I personally feel like I'm spending a lot more time around.
around my kids than I used to.
- 100%.
It was a huge difference.
I think the mental load is sh-
shifted because even
when I would clock out because I
I've worked from home exclusively since 20.
2020, but I started as on as I it was three months before
or the whole world shut down.
It was like, oh, I'm going to work with you.
home twice a week. Nope, I went into the office maybe six more times.
the whole time of work there.
But even so--
like I would log off and still be like checking my...
phone and like be nervous that someone would call me and that I
needed to hop on and do something. A lot of that was
like self-imposed, and here it's just like, no, it's just...
Like, I'm done.
If I need to log back on after.
after they go to bed. I can.
But I am much more present and it's nice to not
I feel the guilt about closing my laptop because my, I mean, my daughter gets off.
the bus stop at 4.15.
I'm done most of them.
- Yeah, right.
you're not in able to be engaged at that point.
Yeah, I get it. Yeah, and just like the
It's the mental piece of just...
like it's all up to me so like if I want to do
it and I'm gonna lock off and I have been and it's
been really great. And it's also nice, you know, just because I don't know if you.
felt this way when your daughter started school.
but somehow it's like harder.
They are more time.
off. Yeah. What are you doing now?
they were with daycare, which has been like a real...
Mindful kind of. Really thought it was getting it easier.
But yeah.
- Yeah, just the fact that I can do that guilt-free is...
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, no, it's...
It's been similar for me as well.
Like I've started taking
Taking Charlie to school in the morning and then picking Billy up for...
school and like Nikki and I alternate with
them and so I just get that much more time with them.
in the morning and the afternoon and then yeah there is
dynamic of like if I'm going to be working while.
It's like not nine to five.
Like, I don't feel resentful.
Yeah!
I'm doing that find myself kind of wanting to go
every, maybe like once or twice a week.
I will.
want to come back after there and bed and just like do.
I don't know, whatever weird thing was on my mind.
before it's not usually client work.
It's usually, I want to come back.
back and like, you know, mess with my position.
or like, tweet something on my website or something.
- Because it just popped into your head randomly.
in the middle of the day and you want to capitalize on it.
Yeah. Yeah.
No, it's I think that that side.
Because...
working in proposals and business development like.
is really in this gray area of like,
Is it creative work?
Like, it is.
but do people think of it as creative?
work beyond saying.
the ever patronizing thing that you've you've
a million times like can you make it pretty like that.
bullshit like yeah nobody really thinks
of certainly the work that I do as creators.
And so having the ability to
to have an idea and not be like, oh, my--
dumbass boss is gonna just tell me no and then stay in my life.
like I have an idea I'm just gonna go
do it. And it works awesome.
And if not, try some else and...
Right.
Yeah, keep moving.
Yeah, so that is...
That has been great. One of the things that.
that has become painfully clear.
to me throughout my whole career is that I...
I fucking suck at designing things.
And...
There is no amount of artificial intelligence.
that can save me. Like that.
The main sticking point I have.
at my last job. Like, I was bringing in all this
discipline that I had learned from Stevie at Blackstone and throughout
other jobs to like the proposals for the job.
janitorial industry that I've been working in.
and nobody would read it, and they'd be like,
like can you have more pictures and
Like just a random shit not
- It's not like we're doing a Keith McClowns.
- Oh, a kill.
me but yes process style diagram like it's
Just like but if I use stock for
like that's not okay either.
So like--
some magic photographer that like there's no money for.
to make these pictures that are actually perfect. That's something that I...
definitely deal with many times as well.
Yeah, just like any pictures or something.
but it can't be too stock.
But all we're gonna pay for is I--
stock photo literally literally something else.
fighting with the client.
Yeah, yeah, I don't know
We're working with that client much longer.
Right.
So.
But and that's the other great thing right like I just like
We didn't work well together and like that's fine.
Yeah, you just walk away.
Yeah, it wasn't like a bad thing.
It just wasn't really working.
I mean, who knows? They have a tendency, like, I think it's going to be
done and then they come back with a rush thing.
and I charge, I can also charge more for Rush now, which is great.
And then I'm like, okay, well, it is a lot of money.
It's so funny as well, dude. (laughs)
Yeah, they're like Colombo, just one more thing.
Just one more thing.
Yeah, and so for.
So the project that I'm working on right now is
It's pro bono.
But I did submit actual paid proposals for money so that...
that I can feed my family.
But the first--
The first thing that I was working on was to get my feet wet and have something...
under me. I can't remember if I just did I describe
I would like to describe to you like this website that I'm working on.
It was for a non-
profit and it was a Kajabi site. Yes.
So a friend of mine asked...
the job that I just left saleswoman there. Her name is Jeff.
Jessica, she is an observant.
Orthodox Jewish woman.
And...
but she works in the business world.
So she is the CFO.
of this nonprofit called Jubling.
It's an acronym that's not an acronym.
and it's just capital JWBLNG.
And you can
go to Jubeling.org and you'll see the website that I've been.
putting together for them.
total like member journey and process through.
like getting people to join and then have at
access to events and then hopefully be able to donate.
That's where they need to be.
make their money like was just an absolute clap.
Like they had this horrible one.
Wix website.
that they had put together and but they also have this
could job you cite and they were paying for both and they were I think they
They actually had two different domains that they were paying.
for for no reason.
an alias one it was just like just two domains and so
So they're just a mess and it's--
And it's because they just don't have the resources to like.
actually have somebody who knows how to do web development.
design. So what I've been able to do is
very easily like learn how to use Kijabi.
like fairly intuitive and I've done the web design stuff before.
but I am not like
I can do the functional side of things, but I am.
or shit at doing the design side of things.
I think that Marcy who...
leads to jubling, she actually lives in Israel and is taking
cover from bombs right now. Oh my god.
that. Marcy and Jessica.
like they wanted to work and like that's what.
I'm donating my time to do, but if-
at some point they're like great it's working.
Econ--
it looks terrible. Like, that's the thing that I
I would wanna pass along to you.
- Yeah.
paid engagement. I would love that. Mm-hmm.
I think that sounds fantastic.
Yeah.
I haven't done a lot of UX.
specific work since.
But it's just on shape since blockstone. However
I still have the
the skills and I could certainly.
take a stab and design designs.
So it's all making stuff make sense.
Yeah, exactly like I'm I've been using
I'm using talk about AI scaring the big users.
out of you and wanting to find something to do in the future, like, propose them.
management at the job that I was at.
I was automating 70%.
of what I was doing using.
AI and like power automate.
And so.
Nobody's gonna hire a W-2 proposal manager.
at some point. Yeah. There's or there's
gonna have one and a whole...
stack of automation that they that can help them process.
Just like plug and play, like, yeah.
- Yes.
And so what I've been learning how to do.
in addition to working on this.
Microsoft, not Microsoft, this website.
project is I'm learning how to vibe code.
in with chat should be to code X have you done that?
with a lot or anything like that.
- Done any of my--
I actually literally have on my list this week.
So I've done, I do.
I use chat GPT all the time and I used a little bit.
of Gemini just because when I upgraded to
Google workspace, it came included, so I've been kind of playing.
But those I do a lot of.
like the research piece like one
a big part of all of the engagements that I've done.
for people so far as starting, especially when we're starting from scratch.
starting with like a mood boarding exercise.
and they take a couple of different forms,
but it's really just like.
I go off, you give me everything.
about your business and then I go off and give you three sort of
dis--
distinct directions that it could go based on everything that
that I can find on the internet.
You just take hours and hours.
and it really only did a little sliver and I do all of that through.
that stuff now. It kind of...
ping pong depending, depending, I really think.
figured out the one that I think is better out.
But anyway, I have clawed on my list because...
because I know that the
like the vibe coding for people who are not.
It happens a lot on cloth.
And there's, I have a client who's doing a lot of
their presentations.
they just like make in Claude now and then like they.
I'll source the cleanup to me.
everything the clothes made in their brands.
But anyway, so yeah.
Yeah, it's on my list.
But right now it's really--
just like a lot of research and then sometimes when I'm feeling unclear on
like upload and like assets give me like what I'm
am I missing? Right. Type of, type of feedback.
back. Got it. Yeah.
I am.
Handful of actual like image generation.
But I find like, uh...
That part kind of makes me feel like my job.
is safe because it's a real pain in the butt to get it to do.
Totally. Exactly what you want to do.
Yeah.
and like, I had to tell it.
Like, please don't do faces. Please don't do hands.
Please don't put any writing in this image because like
It's just, it's the uncanny valley effect.
And it's alienating.
and weird and it's raining.
like you go all over
Linked in, it's this god-forsaken Sodom of just...
AI and slop.
Yeah, and that's the thing.
It's just like everyone.
everything is so like it can get something that's like.
like, fine. Yeah. Like...
Do we, is that really the world that we'd like to know?
- I wanna live a little bit.
- Apparently, that's where we are now.
But I'm, I'm.
I'm really kind of hoping, you know,
Now I like scare myself to death by reading all of these like...
like, no, it'll have a job in 20 years articles.
But then, like, I--
get into it during the day.
I'm like, no, it's gonna--
I think I'm really going to get something back.
I agree and I think the
the judgment, the project management that you bring.
to it obviously but also just the industry background.
that you have from having worked,
which is on a type of federal--
contractor as well.
No, it's check.
Just like full--
Okay, but still like you you
You've been in this environment where you've been in that.
that kind of a business environment.
but you still have this artistic.
work that you're able to provide and I agree I don't think.
think that AI is going to get to a point where
where it incredibly, and...
Do it incredibly do something well as far
as anything that requires like the liberal arts.
Yeah, I think.
It'll yeah.
Yeah, I just keep going back and forth.
because it's funny. And this is I think part
of why I'm...
I'm like having 10 thoughts right now that I'm trying to like get-
out. Sure.
I think the okay piece is gonna take a hit like
Thank God I'm not starting my career.
I guess that's sort of the--
- Yes.
- Like, you know, and having
worked in several different industries and being able to be
be able to like speak.
I think my
special sauce is very special.
able to speak the business speak and still be
be able to translate that to the creative piece.
Some designers can do that.
but I don't know a lot, and a lot of them just don't want to.
So I'm thinking that's where I'll be safe. It's just like
and trying to up level and like really do like more of the strategy.
pieces and something that I've been thinking about.
Try to do the.
The reason that I would as a
as a business owner and somebody who's
uh, hoeing around Row is...
Getting up on using...
using vibe coating is useful not because you're like
I'm gonna make apps now, but because.
There's things that it can do that like...
You're technically vibe coding when you're sending it a chat request.
But essentially what you're doing is it's having it's taking
Speaking, the code repository that it's attached.
It's not just code, it's often like
assets that you're using.
And so when you're--
asking it to do something, it will have...
have access already to all of these assets that you're
already using it just intelligently.
just based on you telling it to do things.
knows what logo to pull in, knows where to position it.
Like, if you're storyboarding something, or if you're just
creating like a shitty MVP before you actually start designing.
designing it yourself, like its ability to
cherry pick all of the things that you need it.
to pull in and then.
[INAUDIBLE]
[inaudible]
Yeah!
on YouTube, click it, send it to YouTube.
It was just a quick file of assets.
[MUSIC]
[inaudible]
[INAUDIBLE]
It's just not possible for me to do it.
Great products like this are for you.
Happy work, people!
[inaudible]
Yeah.
Like I said, it's on.
I'm going to open it up a little bit.
Yeah, that's it's the brand new Google
one. I don't know. I was
It's like
Yeah, I have to try that one.
Consider this a special act.
But they had, yeah, let me see if I.
I can, yeah, I mean just, I'm sorry.
They had examples that I could understand.
understand.
which was very helpful.
I made a copy of one and had it give me like.
like marketing. Like, we're ice water.
become like a LinkedIn talking.
[INAUDIBLE]
to the game.
But yeah, I mean, this is the whole one.
like pre-built stuff that, but it sort of helped me wrap.
my mind a little bit more around like how Vibe could include.
be useful for me, which is something that I hadn't really considered at all.
Honestly, a few days ago, when I...
started reading about.
stuff in the neuron.
And they're like going crazy for vibe-coding right now.
So...
>> Yeah. [inaudible]
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
It can be a lot. It's a lot.
But it's a good like it. I don't know
They have like prompt tips and stuff.
They have a pretty--
They're a website and they've been following.
it for a long time. They have deep dives if you're so
inclined.
clients.
I don't say it yet.
Awesome.
I would love to do that.
Thank you.
And in Tark mode.
really tends to default to dark mode. I'm noticing.
Oh, good.
all the ones that I've seen have been.
Just the background here.
(upbeat music)
So
Yeah.
What did you...
put it in because Chachi PT will not generate
Alright, that's for you.
Is that right?
Yeah.
Oh, that piece of the note is missing.
'Cause I...
I knew this lot can do it all in one.
I don't I have access to call it through client, but I feel a little
weird about, he told me that I could use it to play.
out but I just haven't yet. I'm touching the piece the one I paid for.
So that's what I use the most.
What did you do?
Right.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
(upbeat music)
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I had a great, amazing stuff coming out of it.
[inaudible]
there.
Um, um, rather rather have it and I'm going to
sort of like doing it kind of from the right to the right time.
I'm really uploading.
Yeah.
That's a really generous offer.
[INAUDIBLE]
chat window to the actual coding.
It's something that I just like haven't.
Been a little too scared.
I just don't have a lot of, you know, like I don't have a lot of...
of time. Um, to.
do it and I know it doesn't take a lot of time but like the yeah anyway.
So yes, we'd love that.
Yeah.
I would also be happy to be here.
happy to pay for you to do this with me.
Or like or when I do
ultimately like do your website like what will come
up with some sort of like I'll knock off some of the cost or
something like yeah do apart.
[inaudible]
When the world is in the red red, all the other people are in the red red red.
to lean back on this.
No, there won't be money.
You know, work on the skills you can do with your hands.
Yeah.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
Wow, that's awesome.
Yes, the real life goes.
Yep.
Yeah, what I-
I'm really waiting for us for everything to get automated so that I only
really have to set up my computer for 10 hours and then a week.
that I can just do whatever the hell I want
for the rest of the time.
We're contorted.
(upbeat music)
Yes, oh my God.
please that would be I just
Yeah, I literally just like through the chat with like literally
right before we have done. I gave it like...
I just like dictated like here's everything I've started
asked out about please give me a plan for the week.
Yeah. Yeah.
Which is not the first time.
Probably not, won't be the last time I do that.
(upbeat music)
Thank you.
So you're too. I know we don't have a lot of money.
We're already a little bit over but we talked a lot about my
business, but I want to know like the the proposals and stuff that you
I'm like, "Where are you targeting?"
in person though.
[SOUND]
Mm.
Great.
anyone in a job.
Okay.
your.
[inaudible]
Okay.
Wow, that's awesome.
*sigh* I'll...
You know, got to write it.
in the contracts.
[inaudible]
(upbeat music)
Mm-hmm.
That's awesome. That's very cool.
also feels very future-proof.
For now. Yeah, that's awesome.
Congratulations.
(upbeat music)
Yeah. Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
It lacks the polish.
I love you.
that. So I gave you
you might like newer positioning.
which is like helping to kind of untangle the mess, which still sort of...
keeps that, but the very first thing that I was doing,
which is actually still on my--
I was right now, I think, is one of the--
packages that I was offering was
Hey, you have a brand.
have a whole bunch of stuff that maybe people don't know how to
use documents like brand
guidelines, whatever, like people like, like, let me come in.
and organize it into a system.
for you that people actually can use. It's actually one of the things that I
I did a ton of stuff that I really liked doing,
as I made this like big.
I like really helped to
to democratize.
- Rise slash un- like you unblock.
design. So then like, because it's like boring, like I hate
working on social media stuff.
I hate it.
Like, I'll build a Canva template for you, but like, I don't really want to like...
make them all for you.
So it's that and I had a couple, I had my first two big...
clients actually. Well, one of the clients that was talking about that idea.
and like we started there.
But I did this one big project.
for a client that's a current client of mine where I just like made a whole
bunch of templates for them. They were like in the middle of a weird branding thing.
But yeah, like that kind of like brandy clean up.
I feel like pair is actually really nicely with what?
you're talking about.
Mm-hmm.
(upbeat music)
You're right, but it's like, oh.
Okay, because like the stuff that makes it really.
and apart is hard to
describe to...
someone that doesn't give a shit.
Like, you know, um...
But it does it that like has business value.
And but it's hard. It's kind of hard to put it towards.
(upbeat music)
No.
Dressmaker, right? Yeah, okay.
[inaudible]
Right.
And also, five.
variations of each of those 10 things. That's what I was
Yeah. Mm-hmm.
Yeah, setting up this.
- Yeah, the scaffolding is how I like to sort of think.
- Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
No, that was what I was all about.
about at Sonatite.
Yeah, I think.
I think it makes it just easier for everybody.
Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm
Yeah.
Okay, I think that's awesome. Yeah.
Oh, you bring these guys honestly did not know
that you could do that through Google and I sent up you inspired me to send.
up my own actually yesterday, yesterday, after noon, I was just like boop boop boop.
So thank you for that.
(laughs)
No, I was amazed that I was just...
like I was why I'm not yet.
I was like, I'd like, Cal and Lee, and like,
I don't really want to like sign up for you.
thing and just like feels like so much things but yeah it's all set up I
put it anywhere but it took me five minutes.
Yeah, I am actually going to
to win a win.
[inaudible]
Sorry to add people.
who are of all stripes, I think.
who are interested in working with local governments.
So I imagine I'll be--
meaning a lot of those kinds of people are.
So I will, yeah.
I'll keep you in mind. I'll jot down your email.
Business Card and San Francisco.
your way. Bye.
It is through several...
So I've been doing a lot of like...
Thank you.
So this out.
Alexander contract was amazing.
Like it landed it.
I just like.
ended up being on an email through my
who works adjacent with the government.
I got on this list.
I was like, "Marle, do a practice proposal."
like we'll just see how it goes and then I won and I was like oh shit like maybe
this is something I can do. So I kind of want have been going down the
rabbit hole of like, you know, registering with.
EVA, like figuring out how to--
get my name into these places.
And through that I found Virginia Apex and
this conference or this networking event is happening.
literally up the street like I will be able to walk to it.
So I got the email a couple of days ago and I was like,
well, there's no.
It's like really no excuse for me to not be with us.
And if I don't like it or if it's like a bad scene, I'll just
walk home. So um...
Yeah, so again, I'm just like on all of these like email.
list and things. I actually just got another RFP.
this morning that I'll probably try and go for for creative services for
George
which is like another like school that's like right up the street for me so.
Yeah, trying to find hidden opportunities because
I'm never going to be able to, you know,
I'm like an in-house business type designer.
like I'm never gonna be able to compete with like
the cool, like commercial creative folks.
kind of just trying to figure out where those operations are.
opportunities are and like how I can kind of get in with that.
And I know that there-
they're there and also those people love me.
those heads people because they are so appreciative.
appreciative of like the creative work.
And it's not like I don't need my ego stripped all the time, but just
It is fun to work with people who are just so dazzled.
Bye, bye, you know.
That like good design, it's not hard to do.
So anyway.
Please.
I have seen that man.
Oh, yeah.
for that award.
ceremony was. Yeah, I know exactly what senior talking about.
(laughs)
Okay.
Yeah, or like, yeah.
I feel like I must have an opinion on it,
and I must give you some sort of...
form of criticism, so a lot of that.
Yeah, yeah, it's um
Yeah, I mean like that, like I said, that one contract is right.
the only thing but I just sort of open my eyes to the fact that like oh
Yeah, like this is like definitely a light.
that we could go down.
So we'll see.
Yeah, I'm going to try it this year.
We'll see.
Yes, yes, that was.
through my head as you were talking about it. So yeah.
Well, we'll stay in touch.
Thank you.
All right.
Yeah.
Next week or something.
Okay.
Sounds good. What was so great to catch up?
Yeah, we'll talk soon.
Excited.
excited about this new opportunity.
It'll be great.
It's really fun to work together.
again. All right, see you later.